Hey and we're here again this is Eric
Griffin at all things comedy another
special episode of riffin with Griffin
and I want to thank everybody that's
been listening I thank you every week
and I'm gonna continue to do that and
you know what you know I'm on the theme
song hunt
the theme song search and guys I think
this might be the one but before we go
into I think the new riffing with
Griffin theme song let me introduce
coming to the program the legend my good
friend he works all the time you
probably don't know his name and you
gonna know his name damn when you see me
like oh that's to do from the thing he'd
been and I keep it in so many things he
don't even know his whole resume he
would have a very funny in town to mr.
toan bail
Tom stay welcome back oh yeah your mama
for me so proud she brought me sit there
all the time to everybody to sandy oh
you talk about my baby she just think
I've worked he stay working are you
saying your mom now oh well not mean
like she can't she has a job yeah but
she does you got a you know what mom
gotta have a job just so she don't get
too comfortable
okay stay humble all right so I don't
know like I say I've been searching for
a theme song okay yeah well we don't I'm
not sure what episode it is but this is
in the teens like 14th okay whatever it
is and I'm search and have a new theme
song every week because I'm trying to
find the right one there's one that fits
okay and people send him in all the time
right so this thing you let people make
them because I you know why cuz I was
singing them I what I was doing before
is I had karaoke versions of songs and I
was changing the words but then I'm
getting hit with just copyright nonsense
nonsense
it's nonsense we're like 27 like a law
[Laughter]
classes on the weirdest way and green
can I get to my theme song I'm sorry you
should listen to them
he just take over all right here we go
yeah this is by mr. Randy Reese aghh
I don't know if I'm saying your name
right Randy but this Randy y'all and he
made a good one
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I like that I want people to know that
I'm not just about the hip got a lot of
dope hip hop beats that come in okay I
don't want people to think that I'm just
all hip-hop no I'd do anything I want
some jazz I'm gonna some R&B that might
be the one though we'll see I like that
I'm not sure if that one's gonna last
but anyways uh tone thank you for coming
in man T you know you know we've been
know there's in France for years you and
you are doing so we say man Wow come on
we talking about you and they don't need
to hear about me we want to talk about
like you know we mean let's be out we've
shared on over the glass three four
years just like us you know the ups and
downs of the peaks and valleys that we
had to solve you got to talk about that
we had the same agent yeah at the time
and we would call each other like every
few weeks like bitching about our just
entitled actors job and it's still
complaining if you believe this [ __ ]
like yeah but yeah but we've been on the
same page a lot so yes that's I mean
that's always been but you doing are you
doing good let's just get right into the
the first things we get that out of way
that we could just say you know we're
just gonna Yap this is riffle yeah yeah
so you got the new show is edition yeah
CBS CBS called things off and me and
Nina Dobrev I'm still mad at me
Humana Nina yeah because I'm a huge
Vampire Diaries fan are you and she left
the show so and I've seen her at parties
because she's friends with like Adam
Devine right so I've seen her in Adam
Devine's house it was like right after
that not starring I was like I'm a
grown-ass man talking [ __ ] about some
teen vampire show that she left and I
was like how dare you leave that show
she's here the turncoat is here I would
like you to convince her to come on the
podcast so I could trash her on here a
person I'm sure she'd be very willing
like she's she's dead I'm sorry we
haven't you ever had the best I know
interaction with you but like you know
we've didn't we didn't movie together
last year that's called always sweet
that's how we initially met oh wow and
so we did good chemistry and then you
guys ain't yeah and like because it was
cool cuz the first day we actually met
was our first day shooting and our
characters met in the movie the first
day we actually met her life so we kind
of that was quite almost week right we
kind of just got to know each other by
talking and like rehearsing and stuff
and then when the show came up it was we
didn't have to audition it was like it
was like a phone call thing which is
great like I do multicam she has it but
they're like they get along should we
should they be back together and we
talked and we're like why not we should
try it if nothing else and it worked out
man so now we're on uh every Thursday
night at 9:30 after momma CBS Thursday
night 9:30 fam and what's it about it's
just so it's a people you know like
they're like a formal interviews go
so tell me that you know you know they
do yeah yeah I'm not sure what attracted
to it is like it's a it's interracial
couple when we don't rely on race right
we just we don't bring it up like that
you know I mean like does it come up do
you see certain things yeah probably but
it's not it's not like so it's not
really like the father walks in you're
dating a black you look at the camera
play by shirley rap she never comes in
be like what are you doing baby is not
it's not what it's like it's it's you
know my pick nobody calls nobody
[Laughter]
nobody nobody
however online no I get that a lot I'm
sure you know you know but you a bougie
brother anyway though they no no why no
black girl should be surprised if you
got an asian girl a Lebanese no we're
good cotton yeah yeah yeah you got you
know so it's like I'm with you on that
well what got me is like it's it was it
was - it was a guy and a girl and his
family's like well-off and her she
verbally said her parents weren't living
her dad is but he just was shitty dude
right my mom has actually passed and
then she has a little sister a
half-sister who comes to live with us
but we're tracking me too it is the fact
that you never see a black family more
fluent right then especially in a sitcom
yeah so it was like and we're not gonna
just put it on race it was like can this
work right and it was cooking we don't
really bring it up to like oh I grew up
with money
my mom's a doctor and my dad's a
Broadway actor and her dad is like a
shady cop you know I'm so like we know
we don't we talk about the the like
physical like class and why it's I got
upbringing and things like I'm glad you
know like I'm not living like because
that's how I feel I'm like I grew up one
way but right I love you different
lifestyle now but I don't always talk
about I don't how you doing better than
94 I couldn't pay my rent so what's nice
we have like regular problems and like
family problem so it's called fam
because it's about this like kind of
blended family I know it's not a lot of
people but it's like my mom and dad
myself Nina and then her dad and her
little sister and their listens and
moves in with us so we become parents
before we ready do you think that I'm
just noticing at the sign of the times I
think that there's a conscious effort in
Hollywood to be like let's bring let's
the stop worrying about color and race
and and all that I've noticed it in a
lot of movies you'll see like listen a
little black girl that's a star right a
lot of times her love interests gonna be
a tall white guy
correct you know it just just happen all
over the place so just kind of like get
it out of our heads there like you know
was like also it's now it's now it's
available for you or I or anybody else a
person of color to be that lead guy
would not have to like that's not what
the story's about right
still have other chaotic problems yeah
like regardless of is like man that's
another layer we gotta add if like what
if people just kind of still have
regular last problems what's your both
the two good-looking people too so it's
not like you know it's not you know and
she's okay yes beautiful I love it I
love it death and like we do get along
so great and uh
in this now you have a girlfriend right
I do yeah yeah did you don't your
girlfriend's never like because I before
I knew my girl kind of revision had the
move you you had to move you or love
interest in the movie in the movie okay
so you love interest in a movie right so
then then you get your girl yeah so
she's so she's already mad at her from
that
well no cuz the movie wasn't out yet but
did she didn't you didn't she didn't see
it I mean you know you know you know
that same let me stop why are you
watching my pocket she saw some clips
you booked something and you posted like
you're proud of yourself people to know
and then they go a man congrats and then
it comes out 810 months later and then
they go mad I know you were doing that
you're like [ __ ] I told you alright
it's like one of those things will out
that's the same thing to happen to me
people knew you do they know you're
doing it yeah
they knew you did it you know but you
know they don't believe you and then
when it comes out it's like oh I don't
know y'all was in love oh yeah you did
you didn't read the synopsis this wiki
page on this yeah you could have read
the whole and so oh my god I could
totally see the drum okay so here's this
movie you're that she's a love interest
of great dogs don't like her she talkin
[ __ ] because she thinking they'll never
work together again and then you come in
with life guess whom will be on a sitcom
with for hopefully seven years
[Laughter]
so in love yeah but yeah it's like it
was it was awkward because like it's and
you know you know you get on set it's
like even if you're not having a good
day the money we make is like I'm gonna
have a good day
even if I'm not I don't you know
something could be having at home or
whatever so it's like I got to drown
that out because I got to be
professional right now girlfriends don't
understand people don't understand how
non sexy it is to be on even more so on
a multicam what you because you're like
it's like you're doing a play and it's
like you know these people here and his
crew and there's guys in like you know
shorts with their ugly knees out and
you're supposed to be like like you
thinking like you know what you don't
want I want for like no you just
thinking are you and then and then with
me too were very much like we're okay
rabbit yeah is everything okay is it
okay if I put my hands on your shoulder
yeah you know we very much and it's in
its and is such a there is such a dance
and I will say that I'm in love with
everybody on the cancer and we have we
have that like in it when you say love
with somebody like I'm it's not romantic
is not sex was like I'm glad I'm doing
this with you because if this were
something with somebody else I don't
know if it'd be so this right right or
it'd be more work because you'd be
really reactive like more like I'd be
really tending I be so it we do it and I
and I have a relationship that was a
little longer but less intimate with of
course but yeah so it was it was I would
say for the first month and a half it
was it was rocky I understand it was
rocky listen I did have seen and I'm
dying appear were like you know and like
look at me I don't do you know we're
like before and after you and I right
now with delay or you're like you're
like that I lost 65 pounds like some
draw Butler would do was like we need
you to shave the beard eat the mustache
and put on so but I got this scene and
I'm dying up here where I'm in bed with
these two naked chicks you know and then
like my cuff and was like so it was we
just sort of gotten together so it was
like it was it was a shock to her it was
like a real life did she come to said no
but see that I didn't tell her
necessarily I wasn't thinking about it
but that's a good laugh you know it's
not like I was like that's a good lie
you know I didn't tell you because I
knew this was gonna happen it's the
reason why didn't say [ __ ] I'd rather be
done and we
argue about it in tomorrow morning we
could have waffles that's why I got come
over after the shoot cuz we were
shooting that we're in library where she
lives and and I said she said how your
day what you do and I was like yeah you
know you probably would like it you know
that's all I said yeah I mean but like
which is so large me saying that really
she heard like you know I was having
anal it's just got blown way to bug out
of abortion and she send me a mad text
message like if you're gonna be doing
scenes like this you know I was like
[ __ ] it is show time I got over the next
day then that day okay I'm sorry that
was but you didn't tell her before I was
done but I didn't tell her before it but
I told her after that that's the
argument to subscribe and that's how
like I said I would you did you say this
I'm gonna tell you from now on like this
is about to happen yeah but you this is
well for you it's gonna be different
because this is like a 22-episode you're
doing it every week so you're gonna just
put a blanket but I'm on CBS and we
don't we don't go serous like that I
mean like yeah this was like you know if
the cousins Nina and I would ever get
would would be under covers with clothes
on right my shirt off and she might have
one like is it called a camisole yeah
you know I mean the camisole like the
that's as close as get what did you
smash smash NIC NIC is no no but so like
you you but I feel like you still got to
put out like what a show you to put out
a blanket statement like listen we're in
love on the show there's gonna be some
lip action is gonna be hugging there's
gonna be lots of intimacy yeah if it's a
problem for you I don't think you should
come to set or come to set so you can
see that it's not what you think it is
cuz it's called I'm but at she's
butt-ass naked in bed with me she's like
can we take a picture because my
boyfriend loves you and I think this is
a funny joke that Montez is in bed with
me and we love workaholics it's like
that it's not even like how they think
they think like between scenes I'm on
life so what's up girl like this ain't
the 80s yeah dude
[ __ ] has changed man like obviously you
want to work more than hopefully you
want to work more than trying to go
after something right right right right
you know what I mean you put your energy
into that so that stuff just comes at
you anyway it's like and she's you give
her more energy and I oh my god
I was like if you pay me with a Pammy
when I walk in the door all the love
yeah but that's you know what you just
say if you love her you have to like
just fight through let that insecurity
dissipate and then she'll just finally
it's yes that's what happened the cast
now with the show and stuff it's it's
better than it was of course like I mean
there's very little about coz how many
episodes of you already shot we did 13
okay right right so this is like episode
1 2 3 4 was like I can't believe she's
gonna get sick of complaining about it
and she's coming to every taping because
it's a live audience so like you know
people coming in and so like after that
she's like oh you're just friends
yeah I know they have to kiss was like
they're just friends but all this gonna
take is just one after midnight text but
she could just be like hey did you do
you want to run those lines you'd be
like it is hard then it's hard cause
like all right have you ever very
experienced this were like this this
this has happened to me not just with my
car but like with exes as well girls
because you've been working a long time
have been on a lot of actresses in
Hollywood like 6th Avenue but not a long
time but like consistently for a short
amount time but where because you know
how you don't get on stage as much when
you're doing a show as when you're off
the show you said want to you want to
you try it then you have to get up at
5:00 a.m. and you're like I'm not doing
it just ain't worth you you know you
know who told me that who Owen Smith
yeah yeah yeah Owen Smith gave me that
it was like look man you do comedy to
try to get on a show so you can relax a
little bit to do better comedy yeah so
you can't they pay you nothing here yeah
yeah you can't you can't you gotta give
one more to do it because you love it
you think you need and split enhance
it's hard and so you get but then but
then they forget you're a comic so you
get a text at 12:00 1:00 2:00 a.m. and
people who's hitting you at this hour
yeah oh yeah my friends don't sleep yeah
they just got up if somebody hits me if
you hit me at 4:00 a.m. cuz you might go
yo is this funny right that's a
different I'm waking up for that I'm not
waking ofor what you doing [ __ ] I'm
sleep yeah yeah yeah if I get calls me
goes yeah I need to talk to you right
now yeah I think this is funny
um I want this joke to work too right
you know I mean because I would want you
to answer the phone so I'm answer the
phone a big man and it might spark
something
to go back out a bit I get it they did
so like it's so because when you're when
you're dating a layman you know that's
what it is
yeah they don't but that's why it's hard
a civilian I I feel for her it's not her
fault that she just normal and want
somebody you know you know I mean this
is like you you you're in this weird
world when you start when you date
someone in the entertainment business
and you're not in the entertainment
business it is a transition for that
person and you kudos for her for
sticking it out I mean it's at we're
both sticking it out and it's it's but
it's like is peaks and valleys you know
I mean and that's like that doesn't come
not in life life life is peaks and
valleys you can't enjoy the uptick in
the height in the hilt of it unless you
get those down as well rollercoasters
are fun are you dealing with stuff on
the show that you can go home and be
like oh now I can deal with I learned
something from that experience or vice
versa you take it thing I have not
anywhere else but the they're probably
out of 13 episodes there are eight maybe
nine episodes that paralleled what I was
going through at home and on the show at
the same time or just the idea and maybe
not the the complete scenario because
they're not parents and all that kinds
art right right but just like the
conflict was the exact same thing the
week of our shooters episode I'm like
this so I'm ready yes perfect though you
have to thank your girl thanks this is
like you know you you you doing you
doing like Meisner right now man it's I
guess pissing me off but also like as a
comic you just you want like a little
bit of chaos to keep you on your toes
right but not enough to be like get the
[ __ ] out of my face and it's that hard
line for other people to finally I know
it because this is why I do it yeah but
be like and that's and that's what
arguments with us are hard because like
when you do get into that moment it has
it like I want to hear you but also
you're coming at me I'm coming at you
but also I'm I've trained myself over
the last 11 years to win yeah I find
though that like the problem with like
arguing with your loved one is like the
communication breakdown becomes we're
not arguing but about what we initially
were arguing about now we're arguing
about how we argue because you come up
with a fair point or she's coming with a
fair point about something that you did
and then if you get heated in that
moment then it becomes
talk to me like that and then and then
like some negative things comes out and
now you're spiraling out of control and
in and with us I think just given I mean
cuz it takes you I mean some people
maybe two three years but most of us
five plus years they'll even make some
break-even money to a comedy so it's
like right I've learned I've become so
rigid that when you come at me all I
know is all I know is like
fight-or-flight yeah I got it I gotta
either walk away or I'm coming at you
and I don't want to be that way but I'm
trying I train myself to do that yeah
and that's something that I mean I think
a lot of us I shut down ago if ivory
talked about this right now I don't know
what I'm gonna say and because I I
respect you not do in a respect you
release with my words I'm I need a few
hours maybe tomorrow morning and I'm not
mad at you but I'm gonna get there if we
don't settle that's the best thing I
mean I I learned out you know just even
in therapy about therapists telling me
that like in the midst the hardest part
about relationships and arguing in a
relationship is that this person that is
driving you crazy is also the same
person that you love that's there
somebody somebody don't worry about
cannot protect you like that yeah
so then possible so then what she told
me something that's important to do is
even in the midst of an argument it's
for every one bad thing you say try to
do five actions of love so in the middle
of the argument try to hug okay that's a
hard thing to do because he does that
not push this [ __ ] waver I know
but you know there's something about it
though and the reason why you pushing
away is because it does take away the
anger that you want to hold on you're
saying like it's like yeah yeah but
that's yeah that's good that she does
that because it's like but I think it's
important I think it's important to miss
or grab a bottle of wine can I have a
hug quick kiss and I might I do not
that's what you right now I know I'm not
saying leave I'm just saying like give
me a couple hours to [ __ ] settle and
and then and she kind of forces it and I
fight and eventually our and I go it's
no you still a person it's not cowering
what it is is like it's like this idea
that we want to hold on to being right
but we want to hold on to this idea that
like like I have to get this out I
have to make sure that these points come
across and you understand them like if
how you argue is aggressive and then
actually you're even if you're right
you're wrong yeah yeah so then that and
I think that's why I pulled back to like
I don't want to do this right now cuz I
cuz I cuz I know i'ma feel like that
right and majority of the time and not
with my current girlfriend but in the
past we have ever dated in the past
knowing how I can be I try to read the
defense and then I will have the
conversation I want to have at a bar or
restaurant just so it can't get big if
there's ID an idea that it can get loud
or bright or aggressive then I'm like it
ain't gonna happen at Chili's no it's so
bright right well you be surprised
though I mean probably my storm-off
Chili's doing it happy birthday you just
start going hard so yeah and then you do
you find them when you're trying to like
back away like you going like I need I
need some moment sometimes that that's
translated by the other person that's
like you don't care that because you
can't talk about this right now
and it's like you shouldn't talk about
anything when you're when you're super
heightened and emotional it's easy to
say but it's like it's so hard to do
even talking to you right now I've
discovered the hug that she wants
sometimes I won't give it to her and
she's now she's more pissed because
she's like I was trying to extend an
olive that's trying to tell you and I
was just more just like I don't want to
feel like this right now
because for her she's already recognized
that you are a source of comfort right
and right now the source of comfort is
causing distress as who's just like
let's get back to that and then we can
still talk right that's the thing and
it's and you want the right in my
timeline is a maybe a little this excuse
it's different yeah and so but but I'm
just discovering now that I've I've done
the whole I got to be honest I don't
want to talk we can talk in the morning
if you're okay with that like we can get
into this but I don't know how I'm gonna
react so I'd prefer if something you
want to watch and we'll just cuddle and
spawn I will we'll be together we'll
touch and we'll and we'll bowling have
our
we're embracing but this conversation
can't happen right now because I this is
what I want to get back to so let's
start with this and then in the morning
when it's like time to have coffee and I
will kick it then we actually get it out
and it's better and it's only having a
few times you know we don't fight I mean
we fight it
we fight enough but also our fights are
big and then it's bliss for like three
or four weeks and it's beautiful
but the thing is is that reminds me of
like working out you know it's like you
know you don't want to but you always
feel better after you do it yeah so it's
that same it's like if we could just
hold on to remembering how that feels
and that's why I'm saying in the myths
of arguments that you want to try to do
those those love language things yeah
you know when we talked outside the
improv that one night yeah and I go I
think you're a hundred percent right
because I think that's you tell me how
that's that was my thing and we've been
talking for years in it and even agency
should leave back to this probably the
same idea I mean I don't feel that what
we talked about you know so like so it's
like and after you said that the land
that's probably month and a half two
months yeah yeah little before Christmas
right before Christmas and and I was I
was like man is this how I feel right
and I found myself saying yeah like
that's that's the problem and you don't
know how to express it and you don't
want to say it so Blake you stayed with
her too cuz at the time you were really
oh I was on my way out yeah you were
yeah I saw it in your face it's like you
know having that anger in this like you
know I know but it's also the it's also
what's in the media right now if like I
got my fault she has hers I got my past
she has hers and it's like I'm not gonna
do what media does to people like us
we're to us it was one thing and then
you grow and then now it's like you're
not gonna apologize for that or whatever
oh it's like insight you know you got to
grow from it hopefully you did I grew
from my [ __ ] and now I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna put that on you I need to get
out of my head in my feelings and know
that this is a new person you know you
know what's something that we forget to
do as comedians as performers is like we
don't say we forget to use humor you
know once you really have gotten over
something then you actually can
bringing up and it not be such a sore
spot hundred percent you know what I
mean yes looks like you know I mean it's
not gonna be like we're gonna be joking
but would you [ __ ] that other guy I tell
you this is a real thing oh there's a
ring in his panties tell me did they
have garlic from the vampire a fighter
Nina got me a birthday gift and she got
me and I'll don't you pay for but she
put together his little bag for for me
and she was like hey what you'd have
this whatever and we're in a fight and
so then she I bring this thing to the
house and I come back I left and came
back and she sees like this duffel bag
would like some shirts and some hoodies
in it with like some cool things and
then he writes me as cute no like hey
and it's like really tone like and she's
my birthday yeah was your girlfriend
translated I love your big black no
matter what it said you're a great
friend she's felt like she's describing
it too it looks like I'm like she said
Brown she said balls shaft and a head
like that's every dick if I'm not she's
so specific I'm like those are very
common things when it comes to this
complete yeah
so that's go be it it won't be till
season three they're that they're going
out there hanging out and they're
hanging I wish that I wish I would but
doesn't have a boyfriend she you know
know somebody right before we start you
start dating somebody and yeah y'all
going doubles yeah it'd be great I mean
I and her not hang out very what we
talked and that's what's cool about like
we talked about her night talk about
everything and so I know her life she
knows mine she knows about the arguments
and I was kind of stuff she tells me
about what's not working out of some
cheap going on the date if it didn't
work out so like it's actually good it's
actually really good and it's not from
screen cam it helps us kind of stay away
from each other - yeah yeah yeah she's
an attractive girl I mean she's like all
my friends thinking you know cute and
hot whatever and so I'm sure like I
think she's an attractive girl but also
we know but we also know like look of us
kiss I'm doing something else outside it
is set or not like doing this for real
[ __ ] up everything
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] so not worth it
so it's it's it's a brand hit never
figured that out but it's a lot of
mobiles another figure data yeah this
guy every every leading woman he's ever
been with he got with oh wait I was
about to say always about say oh so this
happened and this is this is one of the
arguments I was coming back from and
it's this is leading into the same
weekend when I had my this is my [ __ ]
yeah you had to yeah y'all could you get
the camera on him zooming in on the
weekend zoom but you got to get the
camera on him yeah yeah he had eye
surgery so yeah so he looks like an
anime character when I do the animated
version of Pham it's gonna be like just
tears coming out of your eyes like it no
I came back I came back from Richmond
and she like she has this thing with
which I really enjoy like and enjoys
wrong word but uh I don't know if you
are like this when I went out I think
the same four or five shirts on the road
every week like I'm Packham to dryclean
they're putting back a bag yeah and then
it's back in the same back same shoes
different aware different socks the only
thing that changed and so I get back and
she unpacked my bag like she'll be at
the house and she unpacked my bag and
then so she took this she want our
peckers she's trying to check she's
smelling them do I smell [ __ ] on this
that ain't my brand right and so she
takes his pair of jeans out that I never
wore Richmond but it's like so but and a
condom falls out of the pocket and now
and I ran into these jeans why do you
have a condom in your pond by good that
way listen listen listen okay and so we
had just taken some stuff out of my
closet like bunch of jeans and like you
know I'm like man you still fit because
I lost a little weight so you know this
is a that why this this sounds like some
[ __ ] I mean that's not like [ __ ]
but I bye but here but here's like
here's how you know maybe do some old
jeans maybe you know you know you know I
don't wear these these are those jeans
from from like two years before I met
you so yeah you had to come with - so
you were there
this condom brandoni make this brand
interested fam on them damn condom the
first and it's in the first kind of
she's found oh no
same bag same bag but this time is in a
pair of jeans okay and I've not worn a
jeans probably since probably December
maybe January I have worn him since
we've been together Malay it's been a
while right right and or maybe I took
him out maybe I didn't wear him but I
took him out like am I gonna win this
with this outfit or whatever cuz almost
warm on a birthday or something like
that right then in a $310 but you like
he's like [ __ ] a condom but and I don't
because like what the [ __ ] is this and I
was like it's a condom obviously yeah
but that's [ __ ] of you because you
know the executive question she was
asking why you got a car of it but I
mean you don't need a condom because you
we together that's like where did you
find all because he found out in my
drawer I'm pretty sure I got rid all my
condoms in my drawer I'm like if you
found this well I don't know where that
I don't know where that came from
because it could be in a box somewhere
where you cleaning something else out I
don't know where [ __ ] could be all over
please I have no idea she goes they were
in those jeans and I go what jeans and
she holds him up and I go no you know I
haven't won those jeans we've been
together almost a year you've never seen
me wear these jeans you've seen me take
him out but I haven't worn him
so it's in deny deny deny your lawyer
comes overlap it grabs the my Jordache
girl you don't even she goes you pull
those out for my birthday and I go yeah
by said well I said look at the pity for
your birthday what jeans that I wear no
perfect oh you went to the evidence and
she goes good for you jeans another like
pair of blue jeans I wore so I was like
I've not worn those jeans did she go
look no nose no of course she was like
first you will do a research Hitchens
ooh and then and then then I'm like I
don't know what to tell you is like a
zit the condom is you can you've seen a
gold wrapper
when they're fresh it's flat and smooth
this is wrinkly as [ __ ] and I go I don't
know how long it's been in there but I
was like since we've been together
not when those jeans and not [ __ ] around
on your promise that and in fact I'm
done let's lose this use this one right
now
okay cat come here girl
actually I didn't make that joke and she
was you ready for it who she was not too
soon and I go did you check the rest of
the pockets what else in yeah you know
and then like there's a Jurassic Park
ticket in there see there was oh you
good for you now there was a good trick
though gonna get all this neat receipts
with your condoms you can be like baby
no that's all what's that receipt and I
was something two pockets it to give me
like please and it gave I mean I was so
vindicated because I was like good no
honey I write honestly did not explain
it cuz I knew I wasn't wrong I'm gonna
get her March of last year you and I was
like look I have not one of the genes
you know I have it and here's a receipt
I don't know if there's the same night
but that's around the time probably when
I was wearing these jeans and so we got
over but also I knew I knew I was a good
do back couldn't there was no way before
me to prove yeah oh that just proves
that you weren't a good dude yeah he was
ready to [ __ ] knows my ready to [ __ ]
geez you know what's funny about this I
know exactly what you're going through
in a sense of like I'm not talking I
rented a car one time okay and I'm
taking I'm trying to find like I drop my
wallet or something like that or I
didn't remember where I had something so
I open up this thing the thing in the
middle console middle and I'm looking
I'm looking I'm reaching I'm reaching
and I pull out a bag of weed it was like
hidden and I thought this is a rental
it's a rental I don't smoke weed okay
alright and I was furious because if the
cops would have pulled me over hello at
the time we'd wasn't legal anything they
pull me over and I and my excuses I need
to smoke weed it's a rental I would
never like come on you're a black man
yeah you know me looking at me like you
know I mean what if you recognized me
too like he'd be like come on Montez you
might just be like I mean wasn't like a
little bit of like a no it didn't matter
I'm not a no drug math either so it
wasn't like it was like a kilo or we're
like you know what it wasn't a brick it
was a Miami nice
like this it was no it was like it's a
brother join us something yeah you know
and now this was like I went into the
enterprise and I was like yeah I don't
clean out the cars do you just ended
trouble I would have been in like to try
it so and that's one of those were you
either believe or you don't believe it's
one of those situations so it's like
that's what you build up trust will kill
them pain and there's nothing you could
do so what I'm saying is you luckily you
had the receipt in there but that's why
in a relationship you have to build up
enough good feeling and and and trust
and understand I'm worried about this
though a breakup happens over some [ __ ]
that didn't anything jail you know more
yeah I know man
and so like that's a crazy thing so like
I mean the only thing I would know to do
is to social media right now like this I
don't have a reputation to be have weed
on me
I don't toast anything about this I just
got this card this is what I felt like I
have to it was crazy but it was when I
was gonna be turning the car in you know
oh she that's what I'm saying I was
looking for my stuff I came up and
driving around in this rental car with
some hidden weed so I'm just saying
things like that that's a similar
situation where it's like so some stuff
you can't explain any and I explained if
there was a flower if there was a camera
with me you wouldn't know I'm telling
the truth but there wasn't sometimes
people tell the truth but you know I
always say this there's no faith there's
no faith without temptation you know
there's no trust
if you know all the answers true you
know so it's like if you if you and your
girl are on lies a cheat code if you if
you guys are on a deserted island and
you say to her that's not exciting right
but if you want a deserted island and
you say to her I'll be back
I trust you well of course there's
nobody here but if you had Club Med in
this hunk week you know I mean it's like
you know big digs getting free it's
every Instagram trainer right out there
yeah Instagram trainers getting free and
like and you say to her maybe I got to
go for two days I trust you now that
means something yeah so that's the thing
you
we want in a relationship but that's but
that's where faith and love come from
and just like desire of like I'm with
somebody other people wanna [ __ ] yeah
because you can't love somebody nobody
trying to [ __ ] with ya yeah that would
be like you resent him you know I hate
telling this story I'm losing cast but I
want imma tell it anyway and I'm really
sorry to this person I'm not gonna say
the name but one of my ex-girlfriends a
long time ago all right yeah we had
broken up and we were watching I was
with my boy I was at my boys house right
it's like four or five of us and we're
watching that singled-out show mm-hmm
okay
and on this comes on the screen it's my
ex and I'm about to say something that's
my ex but before I can say anything all
of our friends were like dude but it was
one of those things I you don't look we
had been together in a while it don't
matter
my point is I like you also know you can
have your own taste you know Matt also
on single yeah I mean that's so like but
it was like sex man I was also on single
down
Oh what I know you're right my current
oh really it was on single
oh what she was am I gonna say your name
either but yeah maybe
what a few I guess we don't talk after
this are we yeah well anyway it is what
it is I mean we should be thanking each
other oh man so tell me you know what
let me get more of your story actually I
don't even know where you tell me where
you from when did you start when did you
know comedies or thinks so so I grew up
in Atlanta in Decatur
I never knew you grew up in Atlanta yeah
cuz that my career started out so
everybody thinks I'm a Dallas gasps okay
so and I do claim douses my estate you
know my sea
I started but so yeah I'm from Atlanta
grew up there
Decatur Stone Mountain Lithonia that
area east side of Atlanta with the
college of Savannah who had a had a was
teaching right after college long story
short where'd you go to college Savannah
State Savannah Savannah State graduated
four and then got a job in San Francisco
no five I was doing like brand
management then I operate after that
went back to Atlanta got a job for
anheuser-busch so I was corporate for
about six and a half seven years that's
what moved me to Dallas and then I
discovered comedy because I was kind of
I was in the acting game in Atlanta but
Atlanta wasn't it wasn't popping like it
is now
right it's not know gee wish it wasn't
that yes that is now so I'm Alice I'll
start I started doing this corporate gig
and I'm like man I really want to
perform and I write I was writing stuff
already because I just I love stand-up
and also I was writing like small like
ideas that are just yeah your story to
tell like in conversation right and and
then didn't know anybody in Dallas I'm
sitting I'm black dude working in a
super white company right and then it
was like some of the dudes of Kools
don't hang out a lot cuz I didn't have
to be in office every day
and then it was like I think I'm gonna
go to a couple open mics look them up so
January December oh seven started like
kind of you know looking at the scene
it's like you know where would I want to
go up and and then January always
started going up you know was it for you
honestly that was it it was like I got I
got my fix of like acting in theatre
without having to do a play right
without sacrificing my corporate game
like when you went to the corporate gig
after that there's something about when
you know you want to do something else
that first time you've had this feeling
of like I really want to do this when
you go to this other job now check and
just yeah you're just like what am I
doing here I am here to they let me go
yeah and the craziest part was like so I
moved to Dallas in oh seven star comma
do eight and then by 20 like oh nine
early ten I was like I think I would I
think I'm gonna do this yeah like I'd
come up well enough in the scene and
like became like one of the top five
guys in my scene and then was like I
gotta go but I didn't want to quit
because I wanted unemployment and so
they were doing layoffs already cousin
company got bought and I was like okay
here we go
severance I'm gonna lay it off I I just
broke up with this chick took me to
eleven because they couldn't let me go
because I was only black doing my
department so it was like yeah I stopped
do I stop doing my reports I stopped
calling on him he was trying to get
fired I was like let me go I'm clearly a
stereotype right now yeah company lazy
nevers working on time I'm like let me
out of here chicken in the microwave not
cleaning it my girl broke up the girls
ate at a time I broke I drove her back
to Florida she moved from Florida to
Texas I drove her back to Florida and as
I'm on on the road we I get a call like
hey you turn in your company car and
your laptop and your keys and oh and I
was like cool I'm on a three-day trip
I'll be back and I Drive it for about
first thing don't worry about him and
and then I get you know I went and
bought because I thought I was hilarious
I went and bought that Brown I got fired
box right for my office depot I don't
even work in the office I just I just
went and bought one of those just to be
like I always want to see if this felt
like I put a plant I blow I put like a
little bond I like a little summit I
didn't thought it was a little bamboo
tree like it was on my desk I don't have
a [ __ ] this right and I just I
dropped it off and they're like you
didn't get the paperwork and I was like
for what like no we've moved to a
different department you have a you got
a promotion what if you what if you were
to be leading another you walk it
through like you're fat and I don't like
your breath and Cyndi no one's [ __ ]
you because you don't you know you just
you would just like to win on artwork of
the waters a determination of the cat
that's hanging on to the tree branch
determination [ __ ] out here yeah are you
walking in there like you've been
promoted
you're like and then you look back at
your damage like they asked me at 28
they were like oh your salaries gonna be
like 97 a year plus traveling I was like
I was like you know only thing I thought
I didn't wanna ruin my comedy career
yeah if I could travel that way and
clubs to I was like I'm Abby he's gonna
die right it's gonna die so I was like I
think I'm good and she was like are you
kidding I was like we know
cuz they cuz that by that time they put
me in sales they put me in sales I was
like you're like anything come across
your desk come on Sheila you know I said
oh I was just doing I was like reading
reports for like this is what happened
last week was like some [ __ ] for three
years ago and I just send that in go
good job I mean and so then that was
April 2011 and I moved out here August
damn it's just the rest is history man
yeah and and I got a I moved in and if
the one of my favorite stories I don't
think people understand but it's like
you have to understand for I worked for
anheuser-busch for Budweiser Bud Light
Michelob all that no shock top all those
like you know huge brands got bought out
so like now it's and the biggest rival
to Budweiser's miller and so I was I
heard three weeks and crashed an
audition and booked a Miller Lite
commercial that's a big [ __ ] yeah it was
the best like retribution I could I
don't think people get because it's like
it's like leaving coke and going to
Pepsi yeh cuz you got that great black
guy commercial look like if you need a
black guy you're the good you get a
black guy actor party with like
seventeen white people and there's like
you doesn't look weird yeah it doesn't
look weird you're that one guy I'm at
they do going like [ __ ] we TV a
commercial first yes I did I did they
evolved I think it was that something
for a lot of common I mean I did
probably like six commercials and didn't
less than a year I had a bunch of
national ones and it was cool and then I
did a two or three episode arc on single
lady so which is my first o ever
scripted thing that was like a like a
kind of like a black soap opera female
based you know like a female anchor so
proper on vh1 oh sure and I had to play
a gay comic my first row ever had to
play a gay comic which at the time I was
like man I gotta shoot this [ __ ] in
Atlanta I have I'm a comic there's
nothing on TV right and I'm from Atlanta
yeah and I was like man this is gonna be
hard to get over so I was like our old
team I told I was like man I need
another job
right now right just two I guess I'll do
it because man it's crazy nobody would
do it nobody black would do right right
right okay I'm gonna cut the Empire now
where it's like you know the black Glee
I like to call it yeah I quit it's like
some eye drops reversed
I know just for no reason it's singing
so you so then you what's the other part
they got you uh Whitney oh right so so
so right after that and that's oh I was
shot single ladies and it wasn't out yet
but then kind of they eclipsed each
other which was perfect yeah cuz we were
like wow that's how is he gay oh you
know are you flipping a chance okay a
very small Tommy Oh Whitney and in a
while you saw me on Whitney and then
only a black audience really saw me on
single ladies so I was like a whoa in
every chick who was like I thought he
was gay you're right right right be like
mm-hmm
and dudes like man I know Tom but it's
also like that's the weird part about TV
and reality shows and yeah yeah
everybody knows whatever you play you
are unless you a crazy character act
right right right
and so that's butBut I was thankful that
they kind of did the same time we're
talking mm yeah 12 it's not that long
ago that we should has changed since Oh
a lot of changes you know it's just it's
like I went to the Clipper game the
other night and they had a pride night
at the Clipper game yeah and it was like
it was special you know it was like and
the kiss-cam and it was all gay couples
well they they didn't know you know of
course they knew where people gonna be
because they wanted to let your sister
pride nice yeah it's the sign of times
we're changing we're moving forward
which is we're not worried about who or
what we look like who we sleep with I
mean eventually maybe that'll just no
one will care about that but you know
that that particular time that was a
toughness yeah so I mean especially when
your careers first started now you like
do I want to be typecast as one think is
that because I've seen we've all seen
you get good at one thing they want to
keep you in that idea nod and so I was
like man if I do this first I might and
I got so many gay offers after it's like
gay role like like offers for like do
you want to a he was great
that dude was like I will do it again at
some point because if the character
calls for it all right down but at this
point you established it I was like I
was like let me get ya now now how are
you [ __ ] why not like I'm a guy on
Modern Family
don't Street yeah yeah he's looking
amazing amazing rich married at the
amazing other movies plays like such an
alpha male I know such a creep we like
this is a great act
but he's so great as that character on
that show so you know it's all
performance yeah you just want to resume
builder to go I'm willing to do all
these things if the part is right right
but and so like it actually did work out
like that in since since they're not you
know if once it comes to work which none
of them have until hopefully now every
year yeah you do like you you're just
like they like show nice Ryan they just
get tone yeah and I can now get I'm get
a little more freedom like just you know
with the writing and in the performance
and because yeah they make you sometimes
when they don't know you like oh he's a
comedian I know they're like oh no he's
a he's an actor and then they go we'll
just do the line has like yeah but I
didn't you hire me cuz I was funny yeah
do you like multicam need to choose
between a single camera multicam is it a
pilot or the show successful well let's
no let's say so pilot you know you don't
know yet both concepts you like you what
network both both concepts you like
equally you know it's like you know you
know they say it's TNT is that because I
do like both concepts equally but the it
depends on what network I hear you you
know cuz I cuz I I was with NBC for
three years for three different series
and I enjoyed all of them equally what
one was a single cam one was a multicam
and one was a hybrid and I enjoyed all
the format's then I did a two more multi
cams and I've done pilots on both sides
the work schedule for the multicam is
best yes the bad is the [ __ ] best
I wasn't designed I don't know if I was
a fan of it thought I think I think a
multicam schedule is great if you're the
star because you know you're gonna be
cuz I didn't know I did our episode be
busy you'll be busy and not waiting all
the time cuz I did an episode of one day
at a time I was in the pilot okay and
man it was like I was waiting three four
hours
well in that pilot one scene I mean
people take about two weeks to shoot the
pilot for multicam yeah it was like a
10-day yeah you know 10 day for the
first you know all these run throughs
and table reads and another run-through
and another run-through and I say I'll
say schedule and gratification multicam
I'll say what I built or what I think
I've built for myself as a comic and how
deliver and want to give that I would go
single well I'll see now that's where
did you say that because I find that
like honest okay like on a multicam if
it's not funny or if it's not working to
me that's all on the creators and the
director because you rehearse and
practice so much and it's so meticulous
like when I did this multicam maybe
there's something like this the director
would be she said it was what's-her-name
oh man one of the she was was that the
great female director she's a prime it
Pam every time I say that people know
he's at home talking about love pay
she's so Mendoza's great to lemon does
is great but Pam is who is I when you
said I was like I'm you talk about but
she's meticulous like this she might
come over and be like we do want to see
she might be like I think I like this
here you know and I was like and she was
like I think you should hold on to the
script because I want because it was
like I want you to get it right right
these are the words you need to say so
if you know it's not like we're cuz on a
single on a single cam it's more about
your performance because you're getting
five six takes correct it's between you
and the editor on single cam but on
multicam it's the director in the
creator's if it don't work it's like
well you know you you force this down my
throat for like two weeks and you know I
tell you can I tell you now the reason
why I love the multicam that I'm doing
now is because now he's the cast great
and I do love the writers and and there
are some small things that I would
change and I but I as a whole I'm all in
on it
right the one thing I've been able to do
is if I don't 100% agree with a joke or
delivery of something I'll just do my
version first in front of the crowd oh
and I've been given most of the license
to do this well that's good but that's
different I mean thank you but I
couldn't do that our the show but I
couldn't do that when I was doing
Whitney
you more to start a show correct yes I'm
saying I must I'm a guest star I'm
coming in and I even if I'm like and
then like you know what's weird as a
performer I know things are different
when you when there's audience they're
like I remember that first thing they're
laughing at parts that they didn't
realize the creator they don't know
they're laughing at something that but
we feel it yeah and I'm like you know
there's and I get and as such it's such
a hoodwink that I feel like I do with
them sometimes cuz I will deliver wrong
in rehearsal so they don't it doesn't
get old to them cuz I know what I'm
gonna do during the live show so I hold
back and go don't kill that yeah I'm
just not doing it for you because I
don't you try to make it better this is
this is good I have better in my back
pocket already so you just let this [ __ ]
sit yeah and then I got you
and so by the time we get there I do my
version of it and then we move on
they're like [ __ ] our version I'm like I
I took you first there's a lot of
pressure though I've been on like you
know yeah I've been on these sets and
like you see like we go to the rider
area in there these guys are pacing
because I know that joke is coming here
comes my joke and I write a joke wasn't
wasn't that the season all right it was
like our [ __ ] was creators showrunner me
oh sweet and I mean if it wasn't my
scene of course other actors as well but
like you know and they'll come in and
try to help out but like if it's a joke
that like you know me and Nina or Odessa
and it's straight up alright we got this
you got anything that's good not if you
know I could pay for it
but it's a I'm punching up a lot oh
right right right which but I love me I
love the idea of us being a
collaborative and so there's a there's a
now season one yeah you trust needs to
say executive producer tone but like I'm
just glad you trust in the AAA
so sometimes you got to take what you
think trust you enough to delivery
that's what you're you're on the show
without even auditioning they're like we
trust what you do so then trust you even
more crazy but when I tell you like I
got nine offers this season nine
really three dramas and six comedies
straight offers of like if he wants to
do it he's in he can pick apart it was I
mean I mean not that you know like some
of the dramas were like we needed
slicked white guy for this yeah yeah
yeah yeah so I'd have been the black
doctor and the thing or this and it all
right everyone I totally see you wanna a
show as like doctor something around
nobody comes but nobody
I'm totally see that now you'd be like
and you'd be all you'd be the one that
arrogant black doctor tunas [ __ ] all
the white nurses and like you know you
you're that guy you read that pilot yeah
well I was going out with the janitor on
that I was an orderly on that you know
how about the one that comes in like I
got the comic relief I know how to work
together soon now we got to do something
well maybe in one of these offers you
keep getting you go can we get yeah
maybe or two I'm gonna send you in I'm
gonna score it when I get my appointment
you just go in it is like hey man will
come talk about this role that we're
doing yeah [ __ ] don't be like oh you owe
and you've been living that makes gonna
be like it might be dumb if it's not
it's 2019 we can't why can't I be told
oh so I'm not happy
yeah look a lot like who likes a
[ __ ] say it you know you come
out and go so we got to hire this guy I
don't know well I mean I don't know why
I can't I should be your cousin who
comes on I think we saw the fam I'm Noel
you do look like maybe a cousin like my
dad is your dad no Brian Stokes Mitchell
is my day all right so he suit like in
cuz man they did me very well going
my mom is burnt you know darker skinned
woman right Shirley Ralph is like a
little more chocolate than me and my dad
is a little lighter than me and you
could definitely be I didn't go little
real Sinbad you like I need to see that
mama wake up like you know better be
black at night be Cicely Tyson if that
eyesore CCH pounder yeah you better be
[Laughter]
super dominant genes so you had sorts of
good-looking so I could be anybody in
your family yeah so you could definitely
be my dad's brother my door like a uncle
to something like that or or or cousin
riff from with Griffin people that start
this letter campaign for me to be on fam
fam G own thing yeah hashtag eg on fit I
like that once you know but yet to tag
CBS please yeah I pitch to show this
year to all the networks but I picked it
I
Santino came in on the show yeah I know
Santino came in and they're like do you
have any buddies and I was like and what
here's this crazy I go I know this is a
weird question you probably shouldn't
answer like this do you want a variety
or our youth because like alright some
some and we had a very diverse show I
mean gay straight black white asian what
I mean everything is under the Sun on
the show which which I really like about
it and I was like it is this character
written is a white head is a good get a
red head cuz it's like then it's like
almost black bodies are you nobody's
already and so I'm like can we cuz her
best friend is gay and so I'm like if my
best friend is a taller white dude
taller than me I'm like I'll sit names
out and actually if I pull the email up
I'm guarantee I put you on there like
cuz I is it's like the receipt with the
condom this [ __ ] can't be
trusted print out for I got here man I
know what we got I want to keep you a be
like yeah prefer ever but I did want to
tell you about what happened to show me
tell me so so so I'm back after we
finished the show and that's why it's so
Sunday night when we worked together
this past Sunday I was wondering if you
saw my set and you were no because
people kept in and one guy that he kept
talking to me in the green room yeah I
had the TV on and I was like okay let me
see what's up here to kept talking you
took off but it was it was a very like
it you know I I am have an eye surgery
for a personal detached retina oh Jesus
Christ and that's why I feel like I'm
like oh [ __ ] is about to and nothing
nothing happened I just literally woke
up in Richmond on Saturday morning and
like I couldn't see a little bit like it
was hazy I can
majority of everything but then like a
little piece I was like maybe someone in
my so I end up getting back and go to
the doctor they're like you should you
should get this fixed for it gets worse
oh and so I went to surgery the next day
so I talked about the experience on
stage for 30 minutes right right right
and then I did a story that people man
people usually get that when in you know
is traumatic are you getting a fight is
something like boxers get it a lot and
so I was like there was a fight but I
wasn't involved I was a catalyst it was
[ __ ] Eric when I tell you here's the
abridged version some do cite some news
talking [ __ ] right Richmond Richmond
funny bum oh my god funny bone long
story Shawn muskie the bullet points huh
on stage dudes talking to his girl a
little too loud I look over the little
crowd work he looks over a man keep
actually [ __ ] jokes oh he was mad
about it I go cuz I know why but let me
step in right here I know also why he
was mad because your girl was probably
looking at you like this in the show
like having a great time Oh what's your
ringtone haven't having a great time I
get it I get it
so then he I never had that problem but
I can make my Messrs rotating like all
updates grow fur is who normally
features with me on the road
grab security do his a security guard
they end up Kooks come out five six
people take him outside they have two
hits his girl he had somebody else he
hit his girl hits a cop - hi I'm so
stage I hit was good Oreo you he says it
yeah I mean with us he gonna hit his
girl in a cop you think he's gonna be
like I mean I'm not gonna black man
black man in Virginia hits a cop he's
willing to kill you yeah
and so it's his cop whatever Annette so
I have the story from the cop from the
with the club manager from Rojo from you
know staff everything what I didn't hear
until too late is after after I gotta
close the show to close the show go take
photos and everything sign autographs
what alright while I'm on stage they get
a call because it's cop that hit
upstairs from that club you've been to
that club right you you know there's a
rock bottom Christmas party of 30 SWAT
and highway patrolmen wear ugly
Christmas sweaters get the call and they
all drunkenly run out they beat this
[ __ ] ass
now he's i'ma kill you you you you you
the [ __ ] from state like so they a
little bit like man you asked me was I
in a fight I'm like I mean kinda I
wasn't involved in the fight but somehow
I got a fellow's yeah so here so I had
to go through so this is like six weeks
ago and so I'm coming back to stand up
and I had to turn out some TV jobs or
whatever but luckily I'm good
another two weeks and I get like full
sight backside 80% vision now how so I
can you're not a hundred percent in my
right out right now okay
from where it started to now like it's
I've been doing all the regiment and
doing everything anybody have to do man
okay so made [ __ ] so I so I went to an
ophthalmologist where I go you know he
does like an you wear glasses you've
been through I examine through like the
you know what's your prescription now
number two number four ELT peasy yeah PM
Bo nine nine
that is not a knife that's my favorite
Family Guy cut away it was like Aladdin
it was like a Latin seven Guevara goes
to the optometrist and Javaris sitting
there and it's just a doctor going
number one our number two number two you
know with the thing and I hate doing
that shake is I'm always like did she
look the same man show me number one
again click show me number two click I
don't talk went out when I was into
specialist at the opt Optim on to send
me to a specialist the dudes doing the
finger yeah yeah and he goes can you I
go Mac and see your hand because he's
like to look Matt got wrist down yeah I
can't see anything cuz cuz it was like
was he's put him so high so he brings
him down and gives it to me some oh so
true my peripherals like left hand I'm
good or his yeah so like my left eye is
good I see everything
most of the right I see but just as one
little section he's like alright then he
looked further and he goes you have
surgery tomorrow and ass where do I go
he goes do you have any more questions
and I'm like nom if we got to do it we
got to do it I trust you you know like I
saw the scans yeah I mean I'm not gonna
just I can tell something's wrong so I
can't yeah and I go is he Asian baby
Hills wedding is my surgeon Asian
he goes what did I go look man it's
positive racism I trust Asians with my
eye I feel like he don't have them to do
on the weekend right now so he's gonna
try to get it right cuz he wants a good
reputation but he might be jealous so
now we friends he watched a couple
movies that did like the dudes great and
and so I went back to the day and
everything but I'm now I'm talking about
it on stage which feels great cuz it's
kind of a dark place cuz the first seven
days after you leave surgery you're not
sure if you're gonna see again you have
no idea cuz they they tell you you have
to keep your face cuz they put a bubble
in my mm-hmm right so there's even still
that what you see is like the animation
I'm sure there's a tiny bubble in there
that used to be I mean I was going to
this but like it's it was bigger than
then you have to keep your head down to
help like they put the retina back and
it's fine what do you mean keep your
head down
I gotta keep my eye got to keep my head
parallel to the floor like you have to
walk like an old man walk sleep eat
relax so if you came to visit me which
some friends did come visit me I didn't
even know which I would I didn't really
tell anybody because you know like you
weren't ready yet because like even
though we're buddies and I want the best
for you we [ __ ] you know tone down
for like 800 for like eight weeks about
time is [ __ ] took a break just
like non-stop
yeah like hey man he not ready for
dishes yet let me let me let me slide in
there and it'd been funny but it's also
like I want to keep it you know also not
understanding like what was I want to
come and said let's do fam like five
years later tone put on some white okay
like should I just can't I can't run so
then you know you're I'm faced parallel
to the floor for seven days oh my god
every every hour so I can lift my head
for five minutes like stretch my neck
but then I gotta put my head back down
and so that was the worst part whole
thing cuz I never hurt people like Manny
were digging you know I woke up during
the surgery didn't hurt I just had
someone give me some morning [ __ ] so I
can go back out yeah yeah yeah I don't
want to be part of that you know cuz I
heard him tell her two surgeons talking
I heard him talking and some dude was
just like hey I mean I can't find my
son is LeBron Jersey and I come to
Marvin Gaye's in the background oh and
I'm like yeah me I hope you find that
Jersey but I feel like we should be
focusing on other things and I should
not be awake right now give me some more
that stuff yeah and so we ended you know
and that's kind of had a relationship
start it so now the surgeon who is super
busy now checks in on me he's like a man
I want you to be good everything any how
do you feel and they and so to keep that
bubble elevate you know rising ascending
try to keep my face down yeah sounds
first seven days and then you know I
lift my head up so not gonna like do so
I can go eat it you know go out to eat I
can do a set you can be on a podcast
though I took a took a I to go shoot
scenes do reshoot scenes for a movie I
did to call little so we're Packer film
and I can't fly because of the bubble oh
[ __ ] I don't really tell many people now
I'm comfortable talking about so this is
the first time I'm really talking about
alright yeah that's great so I had to
take a train oh no from LA to Atlanta
which is three and a half days so two
days to New Orleans
a night in New Orleans and then twelve -
which end up being like 16 hours to
Atlanta two days there and then back so
10 days basically on the train for a
one-day shoot for [ __ ] nothing why
don't you just drive I probably would've
been the same thing you know oh you
can't drive I said why didn't you draw I
took over here yeah but I'm tell you
that the Train is and this ain't I ain't
talking about LA to San Diego train huh
I'm talking like you know you're the
middle of America people who don't fly
who won't fly in just like middle
America where like we're passing through
I mean you would have to take the
southern most route because of my so
like so now I'm going through New Mexico
and Texas and all the [ __ ] Wow and you
see you you ride off along the wall for
the trumple offered 40 minutes and you
see some people going like man I need
want to see that [ __ ] and some people
being like let's take pictures this is
amazing on the train it's [ __ ] crazy
that walls been there though well that
part I wall yeah but people who didn't
know people know there were sections
already yeah yeah people think that like
the borders it just opened walking
across hopscotch into
it's been walls up yeah but they're just
trying to connect all this [ __ ] now yeah
yeah yeah but uh there's some dude on
the way back from Atlanta some dude who
said we had a sleeper car okay so I took
one of my boys had to go to Georgia
anyway so I can he ride with me so they
gave us a sleeper car which is great
like you know he can't go see his family
oh wow and I had a friend to go with
because I couldn't lift anything over 20
pounds at the moment damn and some dude
day too
we hear an announcement hey guys this is
a Scott you know from down the galley he
goes uh you know this is a family train
and everything you want to watch on your
own you can't watch you know just in
public so their kids are bored and and
so me and my money for knows I'm doing
was watching so the next day we go down
to grab like a snack at the little
galley and his lady walks up who we
talked to in the train station before we
got on a train right and she's like man
I was looking for y'all what a [ __ ] if
y'all been we're like over in the back
with people who don't do whatever
happened up here
yeah and we're like you know what
happened she's like man this dude he was
sitting right across from me in an aisle
was watching porn phone up eye level
wearing headphones I might I was like
porn or like Instagram videos are just
like salacious she was like no straight
up porn like hardcore you had headphones
on nobody was an editor and he was just
looking at his work no pants unbuckled
dick out oh that's terrible in the
aisles he didn't even sit in respectful
sir sir respect the other passenger and
so just do it so they apparently they
came up cuz we heard it announcement he
goes hey you know we need to talk to you
and so they go they tapped him on the
shoulder like hey we need to talk to you
like either we go downstairs and have a
conversation or we're gonna we're going
to put you off at the next stop right
and she goes the dude didn't say
anything except okay and then buckle his
pants put his dick away grab his bag and
was like I get off the next stop it was
like you think this is the first do you
think it's the first time I had my dick
out on a train man and I go so much
funny stuff happen on the train Wow that
it was like they were three and a half
days that'll be the next sitcom you
write yourself but man it was it was
like it was silly
so like it's been a lot to came Wow look
look man you recovering you know you
were covering this good I'm glad you're
talking about I'm glad you well I'm glad
you're doing well yeah thank you you
know I'm glad you came on I'm gonna have
you on again in the future you know it
don't forget to let a campaign we don't
get a eg on you fam each if an Indian
family G fam we should go eg family eg
fam hashtag eg fam get me on the show
outlet at CBS now thirsty it but it's on
but if it's on if it's on Instagram is
CBS TV okay because because I've been at
in CBS and it's just something do from
like oh really
Nebraska oh it's not they probably tried
to buy it from him he probably in there
like what I had a TV it make sense cute
yeah that makes sense
somebody had Tom Bell before I got it oh
really yeah he gave it to me
Thanksgiving 2014 a dude's MMS and it
goes I feel like you need is more than
me oh good he was like sign up right
because some people are like [ __ ]
about it give me that bag yes give me
give me a briefcase full of cash
yes I'm like I had a buddy of mine you
see me I don't make that much money
yeah yeah yeah I know what you mean but
anyways tone I won't thank you for
coming on you having this oh yeah guys
that's I don't even know what else to
say I mean this is what we do on rhythm
with Griffin Griffin we just riff and we
do our thing and this has been another I
have an episode
what's that can we go out on the intro
song you know what that would know
because I do I have you got rap around I
got other things that we come on you
know got you you know I have an idea
guys I had you know what you know what
[ __ ] we gonna do it different today you
know we gonna get the intro song back on
again outro song that way this now it's
gonna be the outro song done by the
great tone Bell right now so I just I
played deep you know I was a deep voice
in the back
let's hear it you didn't hear
here we go y'all and I say thank you for
watching
riffing with Griffin and we appreciate
you I appreciate you in
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]